Marc Scott Zicree, Screenwriter/Author: Star
Wars has a very limited bag of tricks. It's like
there's the good guys, the
Jedi Knights and the bad guys…
Film Courage: Why do you like
Star Trek better than Star Wars?
Marc: The reason I like Star Trek better than
Star Wars, there are actually two answers to that.
I was 10 years old when Star Trek debuted and
that was the perfect age for me to encounter that
amazing universe. I sometimes joke that other
people love heroin, I have Star Trek . It was
like it was the thing I’ve been waiting for and
I just loved it and it's been hugely influential
in my life. Star Wars on the other hand came out
when I was in my early 20s and so if I'd been 13
years old when Star Wars came out that would have
been my Star Trek you know and but it was just I
was just a little too old for it to engage me in a
way that would have really been hugely meaningful
I liked it I thought it was a very very good
film but but also I like the Star Trek universe
better I think it has a lot more opportunity
for a wide variety of stories I think it's
much more able to comment on issues of the moment
you know Star Trek was deliberately written
like twilight zone these were Gene Roddenberry and
rod sterling were both men who had a lot to say
about race about social issues about war and and
they said it and I think Star Wars is much more
kind of a escapist entertainment I think it comes
from a very different place but again it's not for
me to bad mouth anything i'm glad the Mandalorian
has been successful I think the more recent Star
Wars films were problematical because they kind
of didn't really know where they were going and
would go two steps to the left two steps to
the right and then you know walk into a wall
you know so it was like I feel very sad about that
because it could have been better and I i think
there's a problem when people decide that they're
going to go deviate from what's expected and go
in the exact opposite direction because often
it doesn't create good art it just creates chaos
so I think you have to be very careful of why
you're doing making certain creative choices
because they if they don't follow the emotional
line then you're not going to engage in audience
and also an audience that feels a very huge part
of ownership yeah and the story and the characters
and that's and that but the funny thing
is the audience's ownership of something
is a fine line to walk because you don't want
to just give them what they want because then
you're just reiterating the same old story what
you want is to give them emotionally something
that's satisfying but also opens the universe
wider does something that they haven't seen before
but in an emotionally satisfying way so for
instance when I came up with the idea for far
beyond the stars for deep space nine it took us
into the world of 1950s science fiction writers
which was something Star Trek had never done
but it showed the audience where we came from
why science fiction was important why telling your
truth is important and it dealt with race in a
very powerful way and I was very very glad that
episode sold and got made and people are still
complimenting me on it 20 years later people often
don't know what they'll love until they see it
you know and so it's like Star Wars you know if if
they tried to describe Star Wars before people saw
it I don't think people would have understood what
it was going to be because it sounded like crap
you know this guy travels around with this big
hairy creature and you know and then there's
this guy in a mask and he's the villain and
he's you know it would sound like oh wow and
you know I want to be a Jedi Knight it's
like oh goodness but then you see it
and what made Star Wars great was that it
was a visualization of everything we'd been
reading in science fiction for decades
but had never been visualized that well
and so that's what set it apart it wasn't that
it was enormously original it was that it was
transferring to film what had been we've been
reading about forever but I'd never seen on
film so that was what made it so exciting you
know flying through the asteroid belt and all
those wonderful things the laser battles and you
name it it was it was great fun it's one of the
most entertaining films ever made so yeah what
do you think the new Star Wars trilogy got wrong
that's a hard one it wasn't for lack of
trying because I know JJ Abrams and I know
he loves Star Wars and I think he was afraid of
of blowing it but but he certainly put everything
he had into it and he certainly did a lot of
things right I mean the you know building a
full-size millennium falcon for instance but um
star wars has a very limited bag of tricks it's
like there's the good guys the Jedi Knights and
the bad guys the the new order or or you know
the the whatever you know it's like good guys
versus bad guys and the bad guys have a weapon
and they're gonna blow something up and you know
it's like it's so difficult and because you and
then Mandalorian has expanded that a bit they
put a baby in it Baby Yoda but you know it's just
there's so many ways I mean I thought I thought
jj was very clever with his version of Star Trek a
lot of people are down on that version but I think
he actually did a very good job of bringing it
alive again and finding a way of reinventing it
but with Star Wars it's like who are those
people who is who is a Kylo Ren who is
you know I mean he kills Harrison Ford we're never
going to forgive him for that I mean it's not like
Darth Vader comes around at last and saves his
son which is a great story arc it's like Kylo
Ren put the lightsaber through Harrison Ford and
he fell down and he was dead you know it's like
you know you it doesn't go somewhere that you
want it to go I don't care if Rey and Kylo Ren are
drawn to each other I don't know who those people
are you know and they're like they're like less
interesting versions of the characters that we
started with you know with Luke and Leia and Han
it's like you don't I mean like Poe Dameron who is
that guy why do we I mean I like the actors very
much I think the actors generally are extremely
good but it's just you know where where are you
going you know it and and then so it basically the
first move goes like this then the second movie
goes like that and then they try and jam it back
this way it doesn't it doesn't flow it doesn't pay
off well at all it's just weak storytelling and
but but again when you view a property as a cash
cow then you just try to get your best people and
try and hope that one out of every three or four
will click and because that keeps the franchise
alive and it's a cynical way of looking at things
and certainly not creative but it's a machine it's
factory but that doesn't mean you can't get great
Star Wars stories or great Star Trek stories
or any of this stuff some you know it's like
each time out it's the luck of the draw it's not
that people are trying to create crap they aren't
they're trying to really do a great job and if it
fails it's it's it fails simply because what they
tried or the direction they went didn't didn't
pay off I think you know Kevin Feige's done a
great job with the marvel universe he's made a
lot of great great films i'm not a huge fan of
marvel but I recognize the artistry of what he's
done you need someone at the top of the food chain
who really kind of has a vision whether that's Rod
Serling or Gene Roddenberry whomever you need that
person who kind of keeps it on track and it's
hard to find those people they're very rare if
you were put in charge of the Star Wars trilogy
how would you have approached it I would have
tried my best to make it good no I mean here's
my real feeling about Star Wars in terms of
speaking as a creative artist I think the truly
the structure of the first trilogy is very solid
and but the Ewoks by the time he got return of the
Jedi George Lucas decided he was making films for
children not broad-based family entertainment in
other words as an adult there's a certain adult
quality to the first two films that the third film
with the Ewoks and all that it's like let's make
some teddy bears let's let's make some products
and then when he went to the prequels he needed
you know he was writing them he needed a writer
who was solid he needed to bring in a strong
writer because this the basics of the story you
know the fact that that the best Jedi becomes
evil and is and then ultimately rises to the
occasion to save his son those first six films
that structure is really interesting but the
telling of it was very poor and so first of all it
was as I say they were films for children and they
were kind of silly but also the writing was really
poor the dialogue was really poor the design stuff
was great my friend Ian Mckay designed Darth Maul
but but they but also when you when you're
thinking of it all as something that's going to
help sell toys then you're not thinking oh
well look here's this great character Darth
Maul why don't we give him a personality and why
don't we have him continue longer in the show
in the you know in the series of films he was
great when ray park is fighting two guys off
with you know with one lightsaber you know it's
astonishing when he I mean he's great and they
cut him in two I would have had him you know stuck
back together and come on back you know it's but
but I think there's a lot of weird vibes
in the in those first three films it's like
hey look you're a 10 year old kid and i'm going
to marry you in the next movie it's like holy cow
here's a babysitter and then you you know next
thing you know you're in bed with him it's like
what you know it just gives you a creepy
feeling you know and and also of course
that kid couldn't really act much and
you know so it's just lost opportunity.
Question
For The Viewers: Star Wars or Star Trek?